اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير الى بانوراما
نناقش فيها هذا المساء
بهدف التسويه السياسيه لازمه اوكرانيا
مبعوث الصين الى كيف هل ستنجح جهودكين في
ارساء السلام بين موسكو مرحبا
السودان شهر على بدايه للشبكات ولا حلول
حتى الان هل المعضله في القدره ام في
الاراده الحقيقيه لطرح مخرج لهذه الازمه
وبتهمه جديده عنوانها الارهاب والاساءه
لاجهزه الدوله الحكم بسجنه الغنوشي عاما
الى ان الى اين ستصل به جمله القضايا
مرفوعه ضده قضائيا
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش الملف الاول
الصين تواصل خطاها في الدخول على خط
الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه فبعد زيارات
ومناقشات ومبادرات ترسل باكين موفدها الى
كيافا لمناقشه حل لانهاء الحرب هذه المره
عبر مبعوثها الى هو هو المكلف بمناقشه
تسويه النزاع في اوكرانيا لهوي سيكون ارفع
دبلوماسي صيني يزور اوكرانيا منذ بدء هذه
الحرب وبالاضافه الى كيف سيزور المبعوث
الصيني ايضا روسيا وعددا من الدول
الاوروبيه بهدف دفع المفاوضات بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا فيما اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه ان زيارته دليل على
التزام الصين بتعزيز السلام والمفاوضات
غير ان باحثين اعتبروا ان زياره لن تؤدي
الى تسويه فوريه لهذه الازمه لكنها محاوله
ستجعل من الممكن توضيح مواقف جميع الاطراف
لحل النزاع زياره المبعوث الصيني بعد
اسابيع من مكالمه هاتفيه جرت بين الرئيسين
الصيني ونظيره الاوكراني
كما تاتي هذه الزياره بعد ايام من محادثات
تمت بين رئيسي لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
اللجنه المركزيه للحزب الشيوعي الصيني
وانجي ومستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيكسوليفان فيينا والتي اجرى فيها الطرفان
محادثات صريحه ومعمقه وموضوعيه وبناءه
بشان مساله تايوان والوضع في منطقه اسيا
والمحيط الهادي والحرب في اوكرانيا وفق
تفاهمات جديده بحسب صحيفه جلوبال تايمز
الصينيه
المقترح الصيني للسلام في اوكرانيا
احترام سياده كل الدول وقف اطلاق النار
بين موسكو وكييف الشروع في محادثات سلام
بين الطرفين التخلي عن عقليه الحرب
البارده ايجاد حل للازمه الانسانيه
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من
اوكرانيا والسابق اهلا بك من الرياض
الهاملي الصحفي الصيني اهلا بكم ضيوف
الكرام اسمحالي ان ابدا من كيف معك سيد
فلو سيد فلوديمير بكل ما تشهده العلاقه
الصينيه الروسيه من تقاطعات ومن تفاصيل
ومن تطورات كذلك حتى بعد الازمه هل يمكن
بصراحه اعتبار الصين
وسيطا محايد
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اخوان
تحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا بصراحه انا شخصيا
متشائم حول هذه البساطه الصينيه او لان
ينبغي ادراك بان الصين هي خليفه
جدا الان الصين هي ناشطه جدا حول مفاوضات
حول عدم نار وخطر سلام الان في ضوء هجوم
مضاد ومتوقع قوات مصالحه اوكرانيا اليست
هذا المحاوله انقاذ روسيا من هزيمه بعض
هجوم مضاد للقوات مصالحه او اوكرانيا بصفه
عامه هذا غريب ولكن
عدم اطلاق النار وتجميد الصراع اكيد هذا
الموضوع ليس على مصلحته اوكرانيا ولكن على
مصلحه روسيا نحن نشاهد بصراحه
عاجزه لتحقيق اي هجوم على قوات مصالحه
اوكرانيا وبهذا الصعبه الان تحتاج الى هذه
ماهله لتعزيز قواتها لتحقيق تعبئه العامه
وبعد ذلك روسيا كمان لي شراء
وصواريخ وبالستي من ايران بعد ذلك روسيا
سوف تهاجم على اوكرانيا مره ثانيه
الان هذا الطارد الموسمين اراضي اوكرانيا
ضعف تعويضات من قبل روسيا وكمان انضمام
الى نادو كمان
بصراحه اذا الصين هي ترغب السلام فيجب بان
المندوب الصيني سوف يزوره
لاجبار بوتين الانسحاب وقوات يحمل
اوكرانيا ها هي الصيغه للسلامه طيب حضرتك
تعتبر بان الصين لا يمكن ان تكون وسيط
محايد او تشكك على الاقل فنوايا الصينيه
واستشعرنا منذ قليل بان السيد الهام لا
يوافق هذا الطرح سيد الهام كيف نقتنع بان
الصين قادر او قادره ان تكون وسيط محايد
ونحن نعلم بان الصين حافظت على وتيره
علاقاتها الدبلوماسيه والاقتصاديه مع
روسيا بل ودعمتها حتى بعد هذه الحرب
وامتنعت كذلك عن التصويت بخصوص قرار ودين
الغزو الروسي كيف للصين ان تكون محايده في
هذا الشان
نعم في الحقيقه عندما نتكلم عن علاقات
صينيه روسيه فلو وافق على ضيفنا من كيف
بان الصين وروسيا من الحلفاء في الحقيقه
هذا ليس
حقيقه وليس يعني كما لاحظنا خلال الفترات
الطويله لسياسات الخارجيه الصينيه في
الحقيقه الصين حتى الان لا تعتبر روسيا
كحليف حقيقي ولكن يعني تعتبر روسيا كشريك
مهما كانت في السياسه او في التجاره وثاني
شيء عندما نتكلم عن دور الصين في عمل
الوساطه المحتمل بين روسيا واوكرانيا او
الازمه الاوكرانيه في الحقيقه اول شيء
الصين لديها علاقات قويه تبع روسيا لذلك
لديها القدره او ممكن لديها القدره
الوحيده لاقناعه على الجانب الروسي للجلوس
على طاوله المفاوضات والنقاش مع الجانب
الدول العربيه وحتى اوكرانيا بشكل مباشر
لاحتمال
للنقاش عن السلام وثاني شيء عندما نتكلم
عن اهتمام الصيني في الحقيقه دائما هناك
نقاش او دائما هناك تصريحات من قبل
السياسيين وخاصه سياسيين الغربيين بان من
اللازم ان تفوزوا الاوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
ولكن في الحقيقه الصين تهتم بسلام تحقيق
السلام والاستقرار مهما كانت من هو الفائز
او ما هو الفاشل في الحقيقه الشعب من كلا
البلدين الشعب من روسيا وشعب لاوكرانيا
خسر في هذا هذه
هذا الحرب لذلك الصين تسعى لتحقيق
لاستقرار مثل ما فعلت الصين لعمل الوساطه
بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايران في
الحقيقه الصين مزاياها الحفاظ بالعلاقات
القويه والجيده مع كل من روسيا واوكرانيا
وايضا يعني لحسنا ان هناك تصريح من قبل
وزاره الخارجيه اوكرانيا مهما كانت من
نائبه وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه بالعمل
للصين للعب الدوري فعال لاقناع روسيا
للجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات وهذا مهم جدا
لان هناك ثقه مشتركه بين روسيا وايضا
اوكرانيا للجانب الصيني
لاعمال
هناك الامل بانه التقارب الصيني بالعكس هو
قادر ان ينفع هذه المبادره ولا ان يضرها
ما رايك سيد
انا بصراحه اعتقد الوقت ليست على ما قوات
مصالحه اوكرانيه مفاوضات من اجل مفاوضات
هذا ليس طريق بصراحه يعني
غير مستعد لاي مفاوضات هدف اساسي
او على الاقل الحديث الصيني عن امكانيه
الوساطه تعلم حضرتك بانه ليس بالامر
الجديد منذ اشهر
وكانت الصين دائما تتحدث عن محاوله التوسط
بين الجانبين الى ان اتت هذه المبادره
الجنسيه هل تعتقد بانه الصين تقدمت به
هكذا مبادره دون ان يكون هناك عمل طيله
اشهر لمحاوله تقريب وجهه النظر
انا بصراحه من اعتقد من الممكن مفاوضات مع
روسيا وروسيا سوف تكون مستعيده لاي
مفاوضات مع اوكرانيا بعض هجوم مضادات
ناجحه من قبل قوات مصالحه يعني
مفاوضات من قبل لقوات مصالحه من قبل
امريكا ومن قبل الصين من الممكن اكيد ولكن
الان روسيا هي غير مستعيده لاي
سلام مفاوضات نعم روسيا تحتاج الى مفاوضات
لكي نقول لتعزيز قواتها كمان كما انا قلت
الوقت ليست
اوكرانيه ولكن
تجميد هذا الصراعات لانتظار نتيجه انتخاب
في هذا الاطار الاستاذ ليه ضيف يطرح نقطه
جد مهمه هو يقول لك بانه على الصين ان
تقنع الجانب الروسي اولا خلينا نفهم من
حضرتك نتخيل بانه نحن بصدد تقديم هذه
المبادره وبص دد مفاوضات ما الذي يمكن ان
تقدمه الصين للجانب الروسي حتى على الاقل
تقرب بينه وبين مطالب الجانب الاوكراني
ونحن نعلم بحساسيه وتعقيدات
هذه المسافه بين الطرفين
نعم في الحقيقه الصيني كما لاحظت منذ فتره
طويله منذ عده اشهر تحاول اقناع الجانب
الروسي
الجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات مهما كانت
هناك الاتصال بين الجانب الروسي وايضا
الجانب الصيني وايضا اللقاء المباشر بين
فخامه رئيس الصين وايضا رئيس روسي
فلاديمير وبالاضافه الى ذلك يعني عندما
نتكلم عن البعوذ الصيني لشؤون وراثيا
صيدليه في الحقيقه نظرا لانه كان سفير
الصيني لروسيا لمده 10 سنوات فهناك علاقات
الشخصيه قويه مع
الكبار من الجانب الروسي صحيح استاذ لهذا
الموضوع لم احد وكانت هناك مبادرات
ومحاولات من العديد من الدول ولكن لنتكلم
بطريقه اكثر عمليه ما الملف الذي يمكن ان
تطرحه الصين على روسيا لمحاوله اقناعها
على الاقل تقريب وجهه النظر لوقف الاقتتال
اولا
ولمناقشه ما يمكن ان تتم مناقشته بمعنى
لماذا يمكن ان تكون الصين انجح من غيرها
لهذه الوساطه
نعم اول شيء قدرات الصينيه لاقناع الجانب
الروسي على اساس العلاقات الثنائيه القويه
بين البلدين وخاصه العلاقات الشخصيه بين
البروتين وايضا فخامه رئيس الصين وايضا
نظرا للعلاقات التجاريه القويه بين الصين
وروسيا فهناك كثيرا من الممكن ان تلعبه ان
تعمله الصين لاقناع الجانب روسي وفي
الحقيقه اريد اشير الى نقطه مهمه جدا
المفاوضات او الحوار دائما يسمى بفن
التنازل او فن التنازلات لذلك ليس فقط
الاجناع الجانب الروسي فقط بل وايضا
الاجناع الجانب اوكراني فكما لاحظنا من
ضيفنا من كيف فان كثير من الاوكرانيين لا
يعتبروا ان
المفاوضات حل للازمه الاوكرانيه كما لحسنا
من تصريحات من قبل ضيفنا من
فلذلك من اللازم ان يكون هناك المبدا اساس
الاسس الحوار وهو
سلام والاستقرار
التوقف عن توقع الحربه هذا الاساس
للمفاوضات ان يكون هناك
اقتتال سيدمير ضيفي يقول لك بانه نستشعر
نحن
بان الاوكرانيين لا يودون الذهاب الى
طاوله مفاوضات هم ساعون في هذه العمليه
العسكريه وهناك اهداف عسكريه لهم ما رايك
اولا لنتذاكر بان اصدرت محكمه جنائيه
الدوليه امرا حول قبض على بوتين كم مجرمه
دولي وهنا نطرح سؤال مفاوضات مع مين
مجرمه الدولي هذا اكيد من الاربع مستحيلات
ولكن انا اعطاك بان في مستقبل من الممكن
اي اتفاقيه بصيغه اخرى يعني
واقعه في اتفاقيهم المتحده وامم المتحده
كمان روسيا في هذه الصيغه من الممكن في
مستقبل اي اتفاقيات معروسيا ولكن ليست
مباشره بين روسيا
واوكرانيا وهذا اكيد من الاربع اوكرانيا
غير مستعيده لاي تنازلات لروسيا ثانيا
واحد كمان غير مستعده لاي تنازلات
لاوكرانيا
سوف تكون مستعيده لاي هجوم مضادات بعض
هجوم قوات مصالحه
روسيه ويعني بصفه الان هذا المؤازكه حول
اي مفاوضات
بطريقه اكثر صراحه هل حضرتك تعتقد بانه ان
رفضت كاف هذه المبادره فلانها تشكك في
الجانب الصيني اولا لا تعتبر هو وسيط ام
لانك بكل صراحه لا تود ان تجلس على طويله
مفاوضات والوضع فداخل الاوكراني
لازال مهتز بمعنى انها فقدت اراضي وتعتقد
كاف بانها متقدمه عسكريا على الجانب
الروسي وقادره على استعاده اراضيها
اوكرانيا قادره لتحرير اراضي المختله
لنتذكر بين اوكرانيا حررت 60% من اراضي
المحتله في خريف بدون مساعده الضخمه من
الغربه
اولا ثانيا مفوضات من اجل مفاوضاتها غير
مقبوله اي تنازلات الان هذا غير مقبول
ايضا لنتذاكر
اطراف مختلفه طالبه مين اوكرانيا
تنازلات لروسيا ولكن
اليوم جنوب اوكرانيا وكمان بكره روسيا سوف
تحتل كل اوكرانيا الان هدف
هذا ليس جنوب اوكرانيا يقول اوكرانيا تغير
نظام في اوكرانيا وعدم خروج اوكرانيا
منطقه نفوز روسيا ها هو هدف بهذا السبب
روسيا هجمت على اوكرانيا بهذا اصابه
اوكرانيا الانتقام من تحدي لشعب الاوكراني
طيب في كل الحالات سنبقى في متابعه هذا
الموضوع بتفاص يله لنرى ما يمكن ان تقدمه
الصين في هذا الاطار شكرا جزيلا لكما على
المشاركه من شوماكوف الدبلوماسيه
والاوكرانيا والسابق ومن الرياض الهاملي
الصحفي الصيني شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات